thanks laura uh hello and welcome to
this special live recording of the no
leadership podcast powered by
intelligence squared
i'm chris host and my guest today is
none other than the sporting legend sir
clive woodward
uh clive when i went onto your website
the home page says how do you want to be
remembered uh and i suspect you will be
remembered as the world cup winning head
coach who led
england's rugby team to world cup glory
in australia in 2003 who
amongst us can never forget not only was
it the first time england won but the
first time
any nation in the northern hemisphere
won the rugby world cup and still the
only northern hemisphere nation am i
right
i think so yeah yeah
um you then became team gb's director of
sport in the london olympics
in 2012 delivering team gb's most
successful olympic games in modern times
and you're now a sports and business
consultant and founder of hive learning
an app which digitizes
your coaching methods thank you for
joining us this evening clive
thanks chris and thanks for introduction
i've forgotten most of those things
none of the rest of us have climbed none
of the rest of us have
we're also joined tonight by a virtual
audience as this podcast is being
recorded as an intelligent
squared plus online event thank you to
all of you for joining us
we'd love to hear from you please let us
know in the audience chat where you are
joining from
tonight's event is going to run for
about one hour for the
first half i'm going to be in
conversation with clive and then in the
second half we're going to be taking
your questions
so please do start by sending them in
click on the ask
question button under the video screen
type in your question and then
press send and we promise to get through
as many as we can
in the time available so clive we we
thought just to sort of break the ice
we'd start as we always do in these
podcasts with a quick
uh no leadership quick fire
round
so a couple of quick fire questions to
get us going and then we'll get into the
meat of it
um in three words describe your
leadership style
uh leadership teamship and partnership
if you could delete any word from the uh
leadership jargon dictionary and what
word would that
be oh that's easy i hate them
i'm going to reach out to you
which leader do you most admire either
so we've seen which leader you most
admire either present
past which leader
yeah i've been supporting alex ferguson
by a long way but always admired him
alex ferguson i'm a big chelsea fan i
hate man united but
ferguson was the best leader i've come
across in support
and what's the best advice you've ever
been given
write things down be be curious but i
think write things down because
you think you may remember them but you
can't so uh
i've always i've even now got just in
case i learned something from eucharist
that's a that's unlikely let's see it's
flattering nevertheless
what's the best decision you've ever
made
uh we went to live in australia um i
think to go and work abroad i
i went there and i was 29 so
i think i stayed up for five years i had
a two year contract with xerox
said that five years so just to work
abroad was really
excellent time of our life and i i think
it just makes you in
independent and i'd advise that to
anybody because chance working
to it and the worst decision you've ever
made
probably not to go to australia about
five years earlier
okay so thanks for that club so now
let's get into the let's get into
a bit more detail um i had a look at
your website
before tonight's recording and it asks
and i mentioned this in the in the
introduction
how do you want to be remembered uh i
was presumptuous enough to answer that
question for you but but how how
do you want to be remembered as a leader
and a coach
i think um when you're in leadership
positions
you know i love the word trust and
respect i always i've always you know
people ask about other leaders alex
ferguson you kind of trust and respect
and
i think the key thing is stressed at one
well absolutely clear but you
you don't get those names associated
with you just because you happen to be
the leader or the
head coach or chief executive you get
them just by the quality of your actions
and you know i always say that leaves
you you you are there to
set the example and you know it's not
rocket sciences you've got to throw the
kitchen sink at it and certainly for
sports in front of you
i kind of still think as a player you
know the coaches who are re-delivering
and what they're doing you know the
coaches are maybe taking a few a few
short cuts so
you know if i hear players talk about me
my time
within what i do now they use trust and
respect i thought that kind of gives me
a nice warm feeling but
you just do it by the quality of what
you do and you know i'm there to make
every single person better at their job
and and you've had some incredible
highlights so far
what was the highlight for you whether
it be a kind of a real
sort of headline achievement or maybe
some specific moment within that what's
the
what's been the highlight well i've been
very lucky because
the rugby world cup win was was huge
because
you know i didn't take the england job
on to actually win the rugby world cup i
took that job on
to try and make england the best team in
the world i mean the number one ranked
team in the world so
to get to number one in the world was a
huge achievement and that's kind of
excellence over a whole long period of
time but that one night in sydney was
just
kind of the absolutely icelandic
everybody could see this was
a very special team and that was just
amazing you know but
we have a fantastic team of people and
i'm still close to all
my coaches all my staff all the players
you just did something that was so
special and
you know and then as you said no one's
ever done that before
from our part of the world so that would
be the highlight
but i've always been pleased i moved on
from rugby pretty quick i kind of
have a bit of fallout if you wanted to
twitch them after the world cup and left
and
i had a year professional football i
loved football professional for watching
fully qualified football coach so even
getting that qualification i was usually
proud of
and the olympic games as wasn't just um
london i was in charge of the sporting
side of the team in
beijing in 2008 vancouver the windshield
picks up to london 2012.
so huge highlights all through that but
what i've been kind of most proud of
we're looking looking and i'm not
finished yet but
he's actually just you know moving on
and not sort of
you know it's great talking about world
cups and lots of stuff oh yeah i move on
pretty quickly
to find new challenges new things to do
and yeah i still love rugby building
you're watching the game but never never
kind of regretted moving on from the
game
did you i mean that the the world cup in
particular
obviously such a such an iconic such an
iconic uh
final not just the winning but the way
it was one did are you the sort of
person that
that manages to find time to enjoy the
moment i think johnny wilkinson sort of
famously said didn't he that he sort of
enjoyed it for about two seconds and
then just felt a sense of relief
were you able to just really the time
reflect on what you'd achieved and
sit back and enjoy it you'd be probably
reflecting more absolutely now really
just talking to you you look back at a
lot of wrong feelings at the time when
the words
there was relief to me it was just a
massive relief in that final wisdom
years later so i mean it's true your
whole life changed
the time and also you know you just know
there's no second chance that was never
happened again there's no
next week i'll try again that was it and
if we've not won that game i have no
clue how i would have turned out
i don't think probably very well i don't
think any of us would have because we
knew as a chance a lifetime and that was
that was pressure but the pressure was
great you wouldn't stop me for anything
i love the pressure of it where
everything is at stake and
you know to actually win it in such a
dramatic fashion
was was amazing so you just feel very
lucky that you you can't take that away
from people
you kind of got it but you can't be seen
talking about the rest of your life
you've got to move on my new challenges
i i i remember and i'm not uh i'm not
trying to compare the two but
but i remember when i first found myself
in a in this in a leadership position as
in right at the the top of a business
and i don't think i felt this at the
time but looking back
i don't really think i had a very clear
philosophy at the time as to what
i knew what i wanted to achieve but i
don't think i had a very clear
leadership philosophy of my own i mean
when you first became
the the head coach did you have a clear
plan
for how you were going to go about it or
did you think did your thinking evolve
as you went through
did you want the truth or just yeah we
definitely want the truth
i i didn't have a clue what i was doing
you know i can i can look back now i can
say all these wonderful things
but it must say didn't have a course i
did but the
when i got the england rugby job i think
the key thing everyone should understand
i had
kind of two careers in business before
that game was out so i worked for xerox
ranked xerox for eight years
uh including five in australia so you
know i was i was
a graduate trainee and i was a sales
director in sydney so i had a
big corporate background but probably
most importantly when we came back from
australia
i set up my own small leasing and
finance company based on the skills that
london was
xerox finance was a small brokerage so
when i say small it's got 10 people that
was around for eight years so i had a
big corporate background in terms of
xerox
graduate training all that stuff but the
most important thing was running your
own company
where you've got 10 people in the room
and when you think about it there's no
difference running
on rugby teams you know and i
really look back at that time running my
own small finance company
that was the key skills i learned in
terms of taking over the
rugby team i couldn't write it down or
anything but you just you just throw the
kitchen sink at it you just work in it
every hour i was i was gone you realize
you gotta
really listen to your people you gotta
make them engage with it but you know
we've spoken about no hr
they're ten people sat in a room and we
took on some big big guys and some of
these big deals like a lot of fun
i learned so much in that yeah more than
eight years
than anything else so when you think of
the rugby team there's no difference you
know
i think when i think about you know
rugby is support over at rugby in
business you know you're
delivering results through people that's
what leadership is about you're not
doing it through yourself it results
through people
when you think of it that's the
definition of a rugby team a football
team
any business team you're just you're
just finding ways to really
you know engage and empower your team
and the way you where you go
and uh i i kind of loved it this was
interesting you know what i love
coaching
i love running my own business there's
not no greater buzz i've been absolutely
the guy in charge
everything's on the line the school fees
are housed
there's no no one looking after you and
it's it's
it's tough i went somewhere with the
world but i learned from both i
was i learned from a big corporate
background and i learned especially from
running my own small
company and i wanted to go to the right
here but often the players would
probably
have to drive the nuts they should refer
to business all the time about what we
did how we did things
you know and um you know i like i think
they learned quite quite a bit and i
made no difference in business you know
and we're here to win and that's
that's the game i mean
it's fascinating i i think you talk a
lot about
this balance between um not balance but
the
the similarities i guess and differences
between leadership in business and
leadership in sport and often in
in business i think sometimes people
talk about sports leadership in slightly
in a rather cliched way and sometimes i
think
um but you have a huge amount of
experience in both it's not just rugby
as you touched on you know the olympics
it's the skiing now it's your own
business uh current own
business hive which we'll come to what
do you think are the big
similarities and potentially differences
between leadership in a sports context
and
leadership in a business context i
honestly don't think there is chris i
really really don't i you know i'm sure
if you've
you put pep guardiola or clock in charge
of a leasing company
and said this is where you're gonna make
them they would be
you know i think and that's what i said
you know i i really love running about
company
like you they love running football
teams i love running the rugby team i
really enjoyed it
wasn't the day i got up they weren't
going to work today it was a business
that was fine through people
you know and the the biggest the biggest
thing the kind of the the two key skills
is just
like a relentless learning you know you
always learning you're always learning
there's no doubt you look at these great
football managers and i
you know i obviously love football so i
follow them closely but
they're always learning always trying to
find new things new actually they're not
sitting there thinking like great we
we've tracked it just let's carry on
learning is everything
and and the key thing is if you get the
learning done through your people
so it's not just yourself you're as a
relentless learner you're
you're encouraging every single person
in the team one of my favorite things in
the rugby team there's no such thing as
a dumb idea you know because sometimes
a new player would come into the team
you know even the young johnny wilkinson
when johnny came into the england rugby
team was 18.
amazing young man superstar player but
he was so shy
he was so quiet he was almost
intimidated by the more senior players
you know johnson and
leonard his heroes then he got me
asking him to stand up and speaking for
these players and he just couldn't
you know so but you know i made it made
it clear you've got to get everybody
involved it was gonna be in their day
because they could have the killer idea
so you've got to get the learning you
know and if you've got an idea
you say it you stand up don't doesn't
matter if you leave your system banter
or
ridicule let me decide whether to feel a
bad idea and i kind of my kind of
leadership style
and it was one of the first questions
you know i actually almost pride myself
on not being good in your ideas
what i pride myself on is listening and
making sure
all these players are really proud to
think about things
and then what i don't think i'm quite
good at if i that's a good idea that
you've thought about
that's gonna you know in sporting terms
make the boat go faster i'll move
definitely
you have to do that's your job so if
this is gonna make you a better team
and more gold medals make the bow go
faster we will do it we'll get it done
no matter what it costs it has to happen
if you're there to kind of strike off
the ones you don't think you're any good
but if they do think they're going to
good you're going to
move forward and we get really good at
that i think looking back at the rugby
team should keep referring to
you know amazing team you know
talent-wise
but what does just the input the passion
the knowledge the thought they're all
playing for their own clubs all coming
together
because they knew we could win this
thing then you knew we had the talents
and players but
certainly so the other team but could we
kind of run this in a different way
where we really do
you know take no shortcuts not be scared
of trying new things not be scared of
failure
because that are going to win i i mean i
i i
love listening to talk about that i know
you and i have a shared sort of passion
if that's the right word for
the power of culture within a within an
organization to drive that organization
success
success or or if you get a wrong failure
and i think your example there it to me
is a great example of the role of a
leader because
johnny wilkins or or you know or whoever
it is more you know
even in our own normal human worlds
people who aren't superheroes like
johnny wilkinson
uh you know if the leader's role is to
you know without you he doesn't stand up
and and speak does he i mean
your role there is to create the culture
and the environment
to make that happen um and i think
that's a critical role for leaders
i think what am i you know i love these
sayings and
none of them are mine by the way i don't
know where i get that from but i just i
always put my name by them it's really
good
but they're certainly not like the sign
of a great leader
but when i'm i'm thinking about this you
know wrong favorites
you know and i said this to players
great teams very great individuals
i repeat it great teams many great
individuals what i find when you
talking to people because i think
there's a magic formula they think is
there's some magic teamwork going on
which which i don't quite um agree i
think if there is a secret to great
teams
if you as a leader my job the rugby team
is making every individual player better
so i'm going to make martin johnson
johnny wilkins and laurence delany my
job is to make them better for what they
do
and if basically if you get every
individual think of your business people
your
your sales people your marketing people
a fall of truck driver
if you invest in them and you're going
to try and make that individual better
you know they will give it back to you
in bucky loads and i really do
they'll know whether you're bullshitting
or not so is this guy delivering is he
making me a better player
and then if you you know in a sports
team or a business here you look around
the room
and suddenly you see all these amazing
individuals who are superstar players
team stuff chris becomes quite easy to
do you know because you've got this
incredible talent and
you're investing in all that all the
time i don't any businesses
quite get that if they think there's
this magic formula to play in teamwork
and i i think
you could never invest ever in training
making people better what they do
because you will get it back in bucket
loads
so i've always worked you know intense a
rugby team is quite interesting because
it's it's so different than a football
team because there's so many different
positions and different sizes
you know you've got big guys fast guys
tall guys everyone
it's very specific so i want to wear
every single player as best i possibly
can and that's a huge challenge because
that keeps you awake at night
but when i run my business from you know
the
secretary to the i'm trying to you know
what have i got to do to make you better
your job
and if you do that you they they won't
forget that and that's why
you feel about trust and respect and you
get that and if you do it
if you just talk about it and you talk a
good game
you know you you can't you can't hide
these people don't know whether you're
delivering them
and and that that takes me to i would i
i could talk to you about the the rugby
team
all night but i also want to talk about
the olympics i remember when i
first met you i felt like i you know i
you know as a rugby fan i'd watched a
lot of the rugby but i and i hadn't
fully appreciated
the the difference in the role that you
took within the olympic team and it
struck me that that you just compared to
the rugby team too let's say a kind of a
a sort of a start-up business almost the
olympic if that to extend that analogy
the olympic team was like running a
kind of huge corporation i suppose in
terms of scale
what would what were the differences in
terms of the leadership style you had to
um pursue i suppose as director
supported the olympics
yeah it was a very different job chris
in the rugby team i'm i'm the head coach
i'm pep guardiola i'm a changing room
i'm in charge my team
the olympic team i was kind of
overseeing the 26 sports
you know so my job was to make sure
these 26 sports really operated together
and there were 26 totally different
businesses you know from british cycling
to dave browns but some amazing teams
and then but
the whole range of sports in terms of
different cultures different personality
fundings you know british boxing
taekwondo hockey so you've got 26 total
businesses
uh a lot of silos that's special by
looking at it very different
some of these sports didn't even get on
with each other you know because they
were competing for funds from
uk support so there wasn't a lot of love
lost between some of these sports and
people
which don't surprise me because i got
there for this job came out of the blue
i was part of a football manager
and a guy called colin moynihan he used
to be the minister of sport lord
lloyd mourinho but i met a couple of
times i really liked him
got hold of me and he said look we won
the bid we know you're in football but
we're going to create a new job
and it's not quite what we do because
it's more of a it's not admin role
because i'm overseeing these coaches i
had to go
head-to-head with all these pretty
aggressive you know winners like
grossman and they're trying to
create a team it was the maid looking
back i'm really glad i did it was
amazing job
um i tried to see firsthand because it
allowed me to go behind the scenes
you know i could go behind the scenes
all these sports you know how they're
saying about being a sponge or a rock
and i have a total sponge i'll go
anywhere
if it means i can learn something and
just to sit in the back of team rooms
and cycling athletics and just see the
way different things will run but also
you can see there's
those you know when you you know when
you look at these superstar
athletes you know from from bradley
williams to victoria pendleton to
rebecca atkinson johnny wilkerson
johnson actually the same
when they're just doing different sports
they're incredibly driven
and they and they want to win but also
what robert kemp got really clear
was you know it's not just one way they
don't just sit there listen to the
coaches
they they work with the coach they
question the coach and their knowledge
of their sports
like you know i talked about relentless
learning before their knowledge and then
then
it was only then i started to write
things down and try and work out what i
had done with the rugby team because
until then i was just throwing
everything at it
but then i was able to actually see why
we were successful and what the
comparisons were with
some olympic sports that were successful
and some of this worked for success
it's a business it was back to the
delivery results through people but it
was a great job but i was more
in an administration role but you know
it wasn't it wasn't playing sailing i
was really surprised that the animosity
between some of these sports because
you know watch on tv that we've all done
the olympic games
amazing tv you see team gb you know one
of the nice track suits walking around
behind the scenes not quite like that
there's a lot of a lot of actual
attention a lot of
personalities a lot of blow-ups and my
job was to make sure
that didn't happen basically it was
you know obviously not named names there
was a few people i just
couldn't believe the way they went about
doing the job because
it wasn't what i used to so i was
surprised in many ways but
unfortunately london turned out to be
really successful which was great
and i mean somewhere you developed your
your uh
or i suppose formulated your concept of
teamship i mean
do you want us to talk a bit about that
yeah the teamship came from a small
business
what what teamship is i kind of read a
lot of
um for every one sports book i read i
read 10 business books
but uh i've never read about team
but all team she was it's very very
simple
but is if i try and make it as simple as
possible if i'm
using my own company i'm the leader of
the team but 10 people in my team i've
been too dramatic
i wanted the team to discuss you know
what we're going to do about certain
things what our standards are going to
be our behaviors and all this
stuff and literally i wouldn't be in the
room and i'd asked one of the team
to you know have a chat about it all the
whole thing and kind of report back to
me
and say what do you think and then you
can become more teachable if you get 100
agreement from the team
but most important the leader also
agrees so if the team comes back with an
idea this is what we want to do we all
agree this
way to do this um if you don't like it
you still back it back so it's not
democracy you're not giving any any
power away
but it's what i said before you actually
you're showing your team
i am listening to you i do i do respect
and understand you
you fundamentally i still think as a
player i could still remember sitting
there as a rugby player
thinking god if i was in doing this job
i'd be doing it differently than this
so it's just empowering your team i call
it teamship
and it's it's it's not easy it's got to
be delivered by the the leader's got to
derive it drive it drive it
and in the end of rugby team we
literally had hundreds of teams she was
hundreds
you know and obviously something to do
with playing the game but most of
our behaviors my favorite one was a
with time i think time to do time for
example
um i think times is more about an
individual team of people anything i
think of
punctuality you know i'm never late ever
you have to be a serious
incident for me no time for somebody but
you know so i sat down on the team one
day i went through all my definition of
punctuality that's starting on time
finishing
all this stuff so i want to know your
definition so i literally left the room
and this is what this is why they were
so good you know mine chance especially
got this
so i came back in and john i gave me a
bit of pay for me said you know we get
this
um uh our definition of time will be ten
minutes early
so if you call a meeting tonight to
start at seven o'clock uh we'll be in
the
room by 6 50. so you need to read this
you're going to accept this the ten
minutes
early is totally possible in the
sporting team so it's not finding a
position in that sense
so you sign off on it and then you kind
of name it we name it named it lombardi
time
um after american football coach called
vince van barde
i promise you anybody listening to this
call if you ever meet any rugby player
who played under me just go to lombardi
time and they'll go 10 minutes early
and even now i meet players everyone's
10 minutes early and they laugh
so your team will create your
culture the most important thing
if i've gone to the team and go right
here's the rules 10 minutes early don't
just hold their arms and go this is all
around attendance because you get them
to discuss it then to decide it and also
most importantly then to recreate
they take ownership of it and they get
hugely proud of it
if anybody wasn't late good doesn't mean
to tell them that the team would call it
out
if you want to win you can have these
amazing teamship rules and what it
allows you to you know if you think
what's happening today in
today's world with all that's going on
in black lives matter
what teacher allows you to get those
things out on the table get them
discussed
don't hide behind anything i think if
people did that a lot more often
and encourage your team if there's
anything you think we should be doing
better
or you're not happy with get out the
table get our table create a team people
around it
and it's it's just so simple and i've
never read about it in any book
it's all about i've been struggling
driven by the leader of the national
team
so the lead the kind of the leader the
leader it almost instigates that way of
work that way of uh
not working almost but not that culture
i suppose but as i understand it
the team almost i'm trying to avoid
using the word police
because that's too uh hard but the team
the team self enforces those rules right
i mean it's not for you to
sort of say hang on i'm gonna tell you
off it's that they they hold themselves
to those rules that they
themselves have set what happens is
we're trying to be the best team in the
world
and literally no one was ever late no
one was ever late
they didn't need policing this isn't a
contract a firm shake of hands between
this time
operate i've agreed to do this that's
how we're going to work
and but most importantly over the team
so you know obviously some of these can
arrive late things can happen but if
somebody unknowingly
arrives late you've got a major problem
it never happened to me because people
have hundreds of them you know just just
behavior language
where we dressed in restaurants all
sorts of stuff and we would
but when you know you've really cracked
it is yes i can put an idea out
and you know you've really cracked you
when your team comes to you so let's
discuss this can we discuss this
can we discuss this and then you go on
from it never stops you always add in
something you're always tweaking them
you're always building on the
for that that ain't the rugby team that
won
the way they operated octopus was just
the best i've ever seen in any business
or in any sport
then you can move it on to the field of
play or you start to discuss you know
what we're going to do from here here
because you're always brains i'm just
saying we need to use these brains these
these just because they play doesn't
mean they're not
clever they're incredibly bright and
they understand the game they want to
win
so just from team ship and you know i
wouldn't know any other way of working
with any team of people
i couldn't i just know how to do it i'm
running you know golf club amateur
committee that's how i do it
same thing you need to have a clear way
is the working that we're all happy with
but but if you if it's nine out of ten
people say yes we'll do it this way and
one says no it cannot become a team
support
because that that person might be right
that could be the killer idea
it's not just every single person
that's what we're gonna do now come a
stage where you as the leader go
okay we're just going to get on this now
even if i'm not quite there we'll try it
for a couple of months until we get on
with this
because you can change it and it's all
powerful but it's certainly my style of
leadership uh so teamship is a style of
leadership it's not a
one offset project so the style of
leadership where you really
are engaging with your team and
listening and taking what they're saying
very
very importantly i i love
in a way fitting these two these two big
concepts we've talked about together
this idea of creating an environment
where
everybody gets to speak you talked about
the johnny wilkinson example you know
you're creating an environment where
he or she whoever whatever the context
is is able to say
whatever's on their mind a worry a
concern an idea
and at the same time then having in
having a framework for a discussion
and a decision with the group as to
whether that is something they're going
to embrace and
and work with um it's kind of two sides
of the same coin in some ways
just because you might win a world cup
everyone seems to think it sounds
wonderful
it wasn't but sometimes it got really
quite tasty in there you know what i
mean because once a win there
rule was there's nothing wrong with
disagreeing in the team room
but we you know but quite simply the
teams when we walk out that door we all
walk out the door holding hands
there's nothing without that team room
but we want
disagreement we want questions we want
arguments we want people calling people
out
that's what high performing teams do but
no one ever fell out there's never
not quite any blood on the carpet but
that's a few few moments where you've
got to go guys calm down calm down
you know and especially look at some of
the games we lost you know we did some
analysis
someone said what were you doing
you should have said that to him and he
exploded
[Laughter]
so we even even that was teamship rules
that when the team room was a magic
place
we had this you know put a lot of stall
on the team room which is
it's kind of more than a boardroom and
we made it a place where when that door
was shut right
it wasn't there for a chat but what what
it has it was quite noisy because i
wanted them coming in with thoughts and
ideas
and i would you know it wasn't me
delegating i was just saying what do you
think what do you think
so you get opinions through them you
know then you've got the coaches who are
no angels either you know andy robinson
and phillard and these guys
they were all one well so it became
quite our place at times but it was you
wouldn't swap it for the world
you know but also my company every now
and then it all kicked off in that
because we
something did we didn't do it right or
whatever and
you know we had so that's why i learned
it from a relearned teamship about a
small company
and you know we may kick off and say
things
in that room but we'll just walk outside
the door high five each other
get on with it you know we set our piece
now
leave on the way behind was another one
of my favorite we have he's done that
just going to move on to put it out the
door let's get on with it i i
i always i definitely think that with
effective teams you you
have to be able to disagree and disagree
to politely putting it but without
falling out you know you need to be able
to have a real old
proper row and then at the end of it say
let's go for you know
we're both coming we're both arguing
about this because we deeply care
let's get it out let's get let's get it
said and let's go for a pint or
whatever it is you you want to do
afterwards because i think if you don't
that's when you get to politics schisms
people don't say their things that they
feel they they
tensions build up i've spoken to
asperger's focus about this about potato
wolf about this
and they say the same thing they always
laugh everyone thinks because you win
there's this beautiful thing and
actually it isn't that beautiful
you know and uh but that's why they all
like but they love it i love it i love
it i love the kind of confrontation
within the team room
because we wanted to win we did want to
win and we're trying to create these
amazing standards and um
i think and actually the players loved
it they absolutely loved it because they
knew
they could and and they kind of the
humor also was
all part of it but you know that's what
performing teams do
sometimes it's not this wonderful
wonderful place that's not the real
world
because you things do go wrong you have
big losses you know
and all this sort of stuff so it can
happen and
you find out a lot about yourself in
those situations as well
you talked earlier about about the the
best you know that
the great teams are made up of great
individuals um
and and you you i think you talked
before about the the dna of a champion
that that just talent alone isn't enough
what makes a champion if not just talent
uh i mean click clear the champion
you've got to have talent because you
start with that
you can't take someone off the street
and put them into a racing car or an
english scramble wherever
so you have to have the talent but i i
just think i i think
everyone's got talent i don't think a
lot of people realize how talented they
actually are
but once you've got talent and if you
really want to try and leverage your
talent
um the biggest thing i come back to is
your ability to learn or really take
ownership of your your own program
yes you want to work with your coach and
do things like that you should listen to
your coaches but
you know i love this tournament glennis
learning where you're actually and this
is what i encourage you players to do
i'm encouraging them to go out and study
find out come back to me what do you
think
how can we do this how can we do do that
and that that's what
that's what champions do we steve regrow
when he was 16 was was nowhere
he's now the most successful olympic
athlete he was 16 years old
you know how he could get in a boat but
he went on to be convicted by his sheer
knowledge of what to do how to do it
both physically mentally
and he took really ownership of his own
program and that's why i see a lot of
these champion athletes you know
their knowledge what they do is amazing
you know then on top of that
you know i use the word attitude i like
the word attitude chris thing attitude
is a great word
um but i don't think people are born
without your own coach attitude so i
break attitude down into ten areas and
each of these ten areas there's a whole
presentation on each one of them
it allows me to measure attitude and it
is things like punctuality
obsession and these these the words it
adds up to here as he or she got
if you get somebody who's relentless
learn you've got the right attitude and
they've got talent you take them
anywhere and um that's why i look at it
so
this is all i kind of developed this
thing over a long period of time and now
you look at people and you can you can
imagine if i coaching and i'm very clear
the coaching process
you know i might think i can prove
anybody when chief is executive to
you know scrum off you know it's the
same process
but you know absolutely one thing
they've got to get involved in this it's
going to be a two-way
piece of work you know if you think i'm
gonna see her just do all this for you
it's not gonna work that way and that's
not gonna be successful you've gotta
really become passionate about this
yourself
and start getting really kind of
aggressive in a positive way with what
you actually do and what your working
day looks like
if you want to invest in the world i i'd
like to talk to you
briefly about innovation as well we we
were hopefully coming to the end of a
very very strange time in all of our
lives
and certainly in business that's going
to mean a huge amount of change
and i think some some creative
destruction probably as well i think
we're going to we're going to see as a
consequence of a huge amount of
innovation in all sorts of parts of our
our business lives all aspects of our
lives
how what role is innovation conscious
innovation played in your uh sort of
leadership
journey do you see yourself as an
innovator as a leader
um no that's about never thought about
it to be fair well what i've always
believed in and this probably changed my
zeros background
whoever wins in it tends to win i've
said that for the last 40 50.
it tends to win a sport i promise she's
no different than
any anything else and certainly in the
sporting world when i became the
director of rugby coach that was the
first time i was a full-time
professional coach
i was you know we had no excuses and i
went massive on the i.t side
massive in terms of because you know
there's no point having all these
wonderful programs
unless the players can understand it as
well you have all the coaches working on
all the it's and there's amazing
software to do but what we did was
at the time probably you know when i
first together in between less than five
percent of the team had a clue how to
use a laptop computer
and he played leicester mike michael i
couldn't spell laptop computer
so this was quite quite challenging
you know if some of the players go what
are you doing
you know they're on the prep field
though you know because all these
tough enough players are walking into
the hotel without laptop computers
and that's the team otherwise now
there's one guy what on earth is he
doing
what does a laptop computer got to do
playing rugby why isn't he
on raw meat was his headline
because they couldn't use this stuff but
it was quite simply going to explain to
them why we're doing this
and also you know they were quite
interested in the technology side of
things and we brought the very best
trainers in
but when we showed them some of the
software pros available the key was
getting them to use the software to
analyze their own performance
but it's on the field of player off the
field of play and that at the time was
just completely groundbreaking because i
was
starting bonkers but you know there were
one or two casualties this wasn't the
kind of
nice to do things i mean this was the
line in the sand unless you're going to
take technology seriously
and i just think today you know so many
people
also you know when i work with some
senior executives
it's amazing you know that they kind of
um
usually want to show me some sort of
software or data to start with
and i i always kind of looked half
interested in the first
few minutes but i'm always going to ask
the first question who uses this
who uses this nine times out of ten
because the badge of honor that's not my
job anymore i'm too senior to do all
this
you know we've got these bright young
things from oxford cambridge down here
massive mistake you've already gone away
from the technology world the whole with
the intent technology is using your
experience
to make sure you make the right
decisions based on what you're actually
seeing
so you know if that's what you call
innovation it wasn't to me it was just
common sense
you know i wasn't kind of thinking an
innovative but
you weren't scared of trying new new
things but technology's
absolutely kids key today everything
we're doing
even about coronavirus it all comes back
to technology and who can move quickest
and who can actually adapt quickly
to what's going on but i guess mazeros
background my business background i had
no fear of technology
because that was my
a very young age but one of your
businesses now is a is a technology
business isn't it
with hive as your kind of coaching
coaching tool
um do you talk a little bit about that
and tell us what the ambition of that is
it's very special it's just it's just
some relentless learning
um basically what what we did was it
just digitized what i did longhand as a
rugby coach because when we first
started
um i use this process when i kind of
break
down the game and we capture knowledge
and information
but when we first started i was
capturing all this information just long
hands
boxes and boxes and stuff so it became
really clear to me that there was the
opportunity
so you just have to capture um
information and this is how i coach
people if i'm going to work with you
chris
i want you to almost imagine are we
going to write a book about what you do
so firstly what are your chapters how do
you break down what you actually do
then once you've got your chapters we're
going to start to capture knowledge and
information i mean really capture it
so this is where this thing comes in in
hand so you're capturing all this stuff
you start to really study it
but this is what i call discover then
you you start to
capture this information about the you
know stuff in one of the chapters
then i use the word it's actually called
3d learning so the first is discover
so you get all the information about
this and you never stop learning always
discovering discovering discovery
the second in 3d learning is what i call
distill
i have all this knowledge you can try
and distill it down to just a few key
points so have all this amazing stuff if
we do these six things really well
the boat will go faster whatever you
want to say and the third
d in 3d learning is like all do so once
you know your
key points your your you're distilling
down the key points
how do we practice this how do we do
this like everything else so your
coaching will be creating your chapters
capturing knowledge and information and
then discover what to still do
and it can all be done on this thing now
it's with you all the time show other
people
and we're just trying to find out it's
all about knowledge and so this is what
the whole
hive learning is about it's about
capturing knowledge and in
um in information but also we provide
content on
other subjects we've got a great program
now on diversity inclusion
the content there is absolutely
brilliant very close to amazing people
who are really ready for fiona young so
so it's the same
it's all on there you're just
downloading chances
so it's capturing your own learnings uh
and being able to
both share those with others and and as
you said
you're a sponge and and enable you to
more easily learn from others is that is
that a
reasonable summary show the people i
would show you i'd show anyone
people do but also we've got our own
content we've got their own content
subjects like diversity inclusion that's
you know because it is obviously
you know the kind of hot topic at the
moment has been
[Music]
it's just relentless learning is
capturing your own knowledge
on an ongoing basis but also capturing
people's knowledge
such as
so i've got i've got a couple of
questions i'm just going to remind the
audience that they
are able to ask questions so send your
questions in and we'll get to those
in a just a couple of minutes i've got
two of my own to finish with
um uh how important is failure been
in your journey clive i mean it's a it's
it's an
occupational hazard i guess as a sports
coach
well i don't know anybody who's been
successful hasn't failed i mean it's
failing
as part of life um i think i believe the
few coaches ever talked about failure
before we failed
we used to
what are we gonna do there's no point
losing a rugby and then saturday
afternoon five o'clock in the chamber
how we're gonna handle that's what we're
gonna do so he's talking about failure
and i think failure
you are gonna fail this is night follows
days it doesn't feel like that so
and the key thing is planning for it so
when you do fly you know how to handle
it and handle it quickly
so there's not this massively complete
fallout so um
and i think i learned this very much
from my business like for the business
thing
what happened what happens in business
and i was totally guilty
to start with my own small leasing
companies that
you know what happens when you without
being too good what happens when you win
the big deal
you know everyone down the block friday
night big success wow another big deal
that's the very
then what happens when you lose the big
deal everyone in monday morning eight
o'clock
massive what happened bigger reaction
what i learned to do was flip that
in other words when you lose the big
deal go down the pub don't ever react
and you win the big deal everyone in
eight o'clock monday morning why didn't
why do we win what are the key points
how can we do even better
you know you hear these terms you know
like marginal gains
under things one percent better that's
all that is so yes you can learn from
failure but i don't think people learn
some success anywhere near as enough as
they should be if you keep losing
go get everyone in monday morning you
know i just use understanding it's gonna
happen
sometimes it just wasn't meant to be um
but
focus on winning and what you know and
then also you can be pretty tough with
your team if you want
you know because you know we still made
these mistakes what do we do how do we
do it better
so yes focus on both but i would wait
far more heavily
really studying why you won i mean
really studying i'm not just taking it
for granted that
you may have won for these really
studying and trying to find out
how to do it better next time we're
going to do it again can we do even
better i think we're getting a rugby you
could win winning a rugby by playing
awful
you know that's how can we win this
better
than that when you get all your team
involved and it kind of kind of works
so they call it success from setbacks
you know
we used to talk about it you know i
spoke to sports coaches they go
you could possibly speak to your failure
we can because if you think
you start thinking the ramifications of
failure you don't want to fail and it's
it can come up
quite motivated crikey we fail it's all
going to have to go through
so let's just part that now we know
what's going to happen if we do lose
let's not focus on trying to win this
thing
any sports coach talk about failure
fascinating
and and and finally so leadership is
often characterized as a lonely place
um whether or not you agree with that
do you ever feel overwhelmed or
certainly in the past have you ever felt
overwhelmed as a leader by a particular
situation or by pressure
or by your own expectations as you were
in very you were in very public roles in
in the past yeah i think it's it's a
lonely place i think you could have one
or two people close around you i've been
trying to be lucky with my wife jane she
knows everything
you know i don't come home and leave it
leave it out in the car i kind of share
things
with and even and then the and the
family you know
you can't hide about you can't walk the
door and be this wonderful happy lucky
person
if you just got beaten again you should
have won it's just that's not the real
world
so they've got to understand how to be
part of it how to contribute to it but
it is
it is a lonely place i've never ever you
know i can honestly say that
i felt i was out of control of the
situation you know
there's been some moments where i just
shake my head um
you know and it's it's amazing how good
you feel in the morning sometimes where
you know you've got to just get a bed
early get some sleep have a beer go to
bed and just
get up early and start again just crack
on with it it's not going to go away
but let's dwell on it all the time and
you know i'm always much better in the
morning
get out of bed eating the days of the
day right you know these things happen
and
also you will not be too glib you just
thank you like he starts you're healthy
it fits
you know you're running around and you
just gotta you know
a lot of people look at you and just not
feel sorry if you just because you've
had a bad time or let's get on the rugby
or that's a big deal or something
just get out there next morning quickly
so um i've enjoyed this i really haven't
and i can keep going forever i'm sure
you probably couldn't you've got other
things to do but we've got 15 minutes
and we've got
lots of questions uh so i'm gonna i'm
gonna um
try and try and pick a couple uh and
we'll try and get through as many as we
can
um there's first of all a question about
culture i'm just going to scroll
to it essentially i'm going to i'm going
to paraphrase
you talked a lot about culture in the
rugby team were there some players who
were you considered to be great players
but who
who you essentially cut from the team
because they didn't buy into that
culture
there was one or two early on i never
named them for obviously no i
i wasn't expecting you to do that well i
think culture
is great and i you know there's one or
two um
you know didn't want to learn computers
you could just see behind your back
they're taking the mic and all this and
stuff so
um you know some days they've got to go
the same in business you know i i think
you know
um you know you said that talent learns
not enough could be more talented person
you know if i'm going to sit down with
that person i'm going to throw
everything at you to make you a better
player
and i'm not going to get a response back
we might as well just shake hands now
you know and if you don't get that
unfortunately most of the players
understood it they they
they kind of got it one or two one or
two of them maybe didn't but they
probably they were
really nice they weren't the superstar
players the superstar
got what i was trying to do here and
they really did buy into it you know
headed up by
the the guys you all know because you
know
i don't think anyone ever spoke to them
like i've spoken before because i get
that
i learned my business background i was
just saying i think we can win
i think we're at the very highest level
but i need every individual
to make some real commitments so you've
got to become the best player in the
world and i'm going to do everything
possible to do that
so the players who didn't have a talent
who they're the pulley ones who kind of
had a bit of fallout with them so
yes they made some changes it wasn't too
dramatic really but
you kind of move on um
do you think social media has changed
the nature of leadership in sport
um players have got huge audiences on
twitter and instagram
um and some players have got in trouble
for what they said online
and there's a sort of a corollary to
this question which is therefore are you
glad you're not coaching now
as a result i know some
social media um i think i'm right the
first tweet was sent about 2006 or seven
it wasn't that long ago
yeah so you know you think the rugby
look at final 2003
you know i never as a rugby coach had to
really worry too much about social media
but players are newspaper columns there
are books in the olympics for example i
i
remember hearing you talk about the
challenges of the olympics yeah but
but some of the olympics came around the
2012 social media was right up there
so it's like all things i actually like
social media i'm not scared of social
media i just think again you need some
strong teachers
okay we need some real strong teachers
about social media
and you just okay i want you guys to
really think about this you know we're
trying to be the best team in the world
an olympic gold medal whatever you're
trying to do you know we're not going to
remember because we're good at social
media we're causing advocate on social
media so we need to
you know and with the olympic team i
think we had about 10 teamship rules
around social media
but none of them were saying you know we
could have just banned it try to
just create a war we just try to do the
opposite it's really gauging really
engage with it
because it's a good thing so it's it's
actually a good tool if it's used
correctly
and but you know players as players i
think don't know you you are
pressing pressing one button your career
is ruined
it's a serious serious stuff there so
you gotta take it seriously you're gonna
have your teamship rules you're gonna
get buy-in
and again in the olympic games in 2012
i'm so proud it wasn't a single
single social media message from any
athlete that anyone took offense about
because we didn't always work with about
how to handle it what to do
they all used it and what i'd say to you
know if you think about it
if you're used to using social media and
then olympic games come up you stop it
that's not the right behavior you want
to
do you know when you go to rugby games
olympic games one of your behaviors is
the way you live your life could be the
same
so if you take this away or ban it you
just create this problem
so it's a case of understanding it using
it correctly
um it certainly doesn't scare me in
terms of what is it that's not the
reason
i'm not coaching at all i'm going to try
i don't use that much
um because i find myself reading it too
much what i have found
you know i've really tried to take it
off the phone almost if there's
something i think i need to share with
people
and people might find injured i don't
put it on my twitter account but also i
don't go on it
so i just found myself spending far too
much time look at my
phone and life's too short it's whenever
you look at your phone reading other
people's messages
a question about a person you cited
right at the start alex ferguson
um how much uh should leaders use anger
alex ferguson could famously be furious
jose mourinho seems frequently unhappy
shouldn't leaders be optimistic and
caring
uh yeah the answer is yeah i mean alex
ferguson
for 95 percent of his time
caring and all that stuff but every now
and then
you have to i i did it once being a
rugby team where i
absolutely lost it the change of it lost
it completely you know
and uh but it kind of worked because
they've never seen me like that before
because i needed to shock them possibly
shot them
and not go through what we normally
would do which was kind of this very
professional half-time routine and all
this sort of stuff
that was it wasn't the classic teacup
hairdryer moment
and you can't do it all the time or they
get fed up with they're just laughing
but if if when it's needed you have to
be emotional i've been out there
but it's just getting the balance right
and i i i didn't ever plan to do it
just every now and then you've got to do
as a coach and there's been some famous
moments with ferguson i think he kept
beckham's
accident but he did chuck something but
yeah i think that's good
i'll say business every now and then
you've got to
become across that this is you're not
happy with things
and but you've just got a business be a
little bit more clear in your thinking
so you don't actually
say something you that you may really
really regret in terms of
upsetting somebody
well um is there anything
so is there anything that you look back
on
either at the olympics or the rugby team
and think i would do that differently
now
if i was in that position again like big
decisions you faced that you would have
know because changed you've kind of just
done you can't change it you're going to
move on
so i would have already learned if i
made a bad decision
sat down on the monday don't i just
explain to you you know what happens
um don't don't do it again but there's
not this it's all it's all part of it as
long as you come out the other end one
day kind of smiling
you can really get this stressed should
i
should have done that i mean you know at
the time
you're doing it at the best wheels yeah
you look back in maybe
odds selections with a guy maybe but
big deal you've got to move on you know
you can't change i know
we've got most crystals all right so i'm
going to squeeze two more in
um a question from andrew wilson what is
the greatest challenge
facing leaders today uh and this is sort
of
an additional question from andrew what
are your favorite questions to ask of
those who you lead
i think the biggest challenge today is
what's going on i mean
no one has ever been trained or you've
thought about what to do in this
situation
so that's where the real strong leaders
will come through you know this will
look back at this moment in time and
hopefully some some organizations some
company some teams have come through
really strong others will fail
and and it's this case of hopefully
you've had some sort of planning for it
going forward
you could have planned for the coroner
but your main disaster could have been
happened so it's again the just case of
the plot planning and
learning trying to predict these things
um
and actually getting ready ready for it
so i forgot
about that question the second part of
the question was
um what are your favorite questions to
ask
of those who you lead
yeah i just asked them in terms of their
learning just just you know show me what
you
show what you've learned today show you
what you're doing can they show me
anything
show me their history and if they can't
we've got to start quickly because
it's all just stuck in your head the
chance that i'll be stuck in here and
you'll
keep forgetting it so i just want to
know
you know what they do on a regular basis
to capture their own learnings capture
their expertise
and how can i help improve that because
i think we can do it better if we if we
work through that 3d
learning process and get it and the
people understanding that
and it's almost like i want to capture
your ip i want to make it better i want
to capture it steady and how can we i
could make you better
what you actually do so that's my
favorite question in a roundabout way
and and the final question from francis
cody
i you've talked a lot about this during
the past hour so i think i can guess the
answer
but do we need to employ more people in
corporations who've run their own small
businesses
wouldn't say corporation i said
governments i would say people
people who are used to making decisions
haven't had a big
corporation behind them you know they've
really been on the line because
they're the people i really admired it's
a small business mindset
because it's tough being a small you
know it's not small in terms of small
it's just
in numbers and i i think some of the
um you know the best business leaders i
i know
have all started off on their own
companies they've learnt and
learned good lessons bad lessons they've
learned how to win they learn how to
fail which is really important
but they have to make decisions and i i
think sometimes
top people in companies if they've got
there without ever having to really make
a decision because they've always had
the backing
of a big corporation behind the same in
government like what have they really
done
and you really get against the wall like
we are at the moment what have they
really done to prove they've got the
kind of the mindset the bottle the spine
to kind of get through this because it's
a business that's what it is
so uh and thank you very much clive
for for your time for being with us and
for the absolutely fascinating chat i've
learned loads
i'm convinced i'm sure the audience have
as well uh
thank you to the audience for joining us
and to intelligence squared for putting
this evening's conversation together
i've still enjoyed it and i hope you
have too and back to you farah
thank you so much chris and thank you
clive it was a fascinating conversation
on leadership and we'd love for you to
join us again
uh audience members next tuesday we have
the labour mp david lami speaking to
samira ahmed
about his personal and political journey
in our award-winning podcast
how i found my voice in a few weeks we
have salman rushdie the author speaking
to brazil iqbal
and many more events on our website do
check it out at intelligentsquared.com
thank you and from all of us at
intelligent squad have a good evening
you